[Music]
look at johnny's situation
you are never going to win in that
situation
off the rip
true
maybe in the long run like two years
later
you might try to do something like this
right
but it's too late
damage is done he's lost how much how
many deals how much millions but guess
what how much what the stigma so so the
point i'm making is that right
unfortunately in life right i'm at the
point like i understand that there are
certain scenarios in certain situation
where
women have the upper hand
and there are other situations where men
are the upper hand is the life that we
live in and unfortunately the society
that we live in the being putting hands
on a woman that's just one of the things
that they've got up a hand on do you
think that women would act better if
they were afraid to be hit
i think if they change the laws
i think if they change the laws around
how men are treated when when police
arrive on the first response
and the woman goes i'm the victim
right they don't care if the man is
bleeding and half dead
if she got one if she has one little
automatically he's going to jail for
that night we will hear your story
another time another time yeah so i
think if they change the laws around
that and women start to see that yo
it's no longer that way i think it might
change things but as long as that the
law is on the women's side the way it is
right now they're never going to give
and i think i'm thinking more of that
from that perspective you're very you're
very right in everything you said
but the type of person i i'm willing to
take that risk
i'll tell you so let me tell
um
obviously if a woman hits me i'm not you
know immediately going to hit you back
yeah it has to be repeated yeah i would
warn you hey stop it i'll try to
restrain it but there's a way you might
probably maybe
you you're slapping me at first i'm
trying to restrain you then you you take
exactly as a strong woman yeah i i'm an
[ __ ] too so
you punch me or something how would you
know absolutely i don't mind like when
the police come it's fine
i mean i'm in cell i'm in jail yeah
happy you know i'm laying down in my
cell and i'm like say happy birthday
[Laughter]
it's okay it's okay but
i feel like i've done other many people
yeah when you see a man next time you
wouldn't do that
i'm the sacrificial lamb yeah i'm i'm
the i'm the master king of
yeah yeah teach you that lesson
for
like i said i don't disagree with you
man's point of view of this fight but if
you're brave enough to hit a man
you need to understand the consequences
with that i don't
disagree i'm just talking from my
perspective like
no you're right i think i think what i
would do things need to change on a
societal level for example
the guys need a me too kind of movement
where one person says yeah men too
yeah
meant to like one person drops it and
then this guy's you know what i'm saying
if that happens and
women who abuse men start to get shamed
then we can probably get some traction
you know what i'm saying so it needs to
happen that way i'm not saying mentions
just start hitting women they're going
to have me to in
yeah just one person just needs to be
brave
i feel like for me
i'm kind of like on his side and what
you're saying basically i know as a
boxer you are no woman
no woman should be hitting any man
because i feel like
different people have different
thresholds right so yeah you could hit
someone like yourself you got some
people that um so there's how i i put it
there's three categories of men yeah
so you got the first one which is you
probably fall under that bracket of
if you hit me i'm gonna take
yeah then you got the second layer which
i probably fall under that bracket if
you hit me
i'll probably hit you back yeah but
mine's not on the level of like what's
number one what's number one number one
is you you you have the thing you just
walk away you have to understand how the
hell take the l get punched depending
whatever then you got the second
threshold which is
okay cool
you might hit someone you know someone
if someone hits you you're
naturally and then you come back to your
senses
that's it that's probably the level i
follow i was the third one the flat
level is
once they're same guys once they see red
they see red
so they're really like you know what i'm
saying sorry guys even even chitchat
they don't they're not taking chicks
yeah
chit chat they're not once they see him
when you said that i'm not playing i'm
saying he made the point
yeah yeah yeah the second one
some people when that happens they have
the time to oh oh come back to their
senses right then you got people once
that red is red
they're not stopping until they're
satisfied that you know what i'm
comfortable not even now you understand
so which means some some people might
not come back some people might some
women might end up in the hospital right
or whatever
my advice is always
don't put your hands on anybody even me
that's a man yeah
you don't know how i get we get
arguments whatever i know within myself
you don't put your hands on another
human being like you understand it's not
you don't do it so if me as a man know
like okay cool there might be some
people i might feel like okay cool
physically i look like i can say i still
know within myself
because i don't do that so when i ask
you a question go on
knowing
that women
are like
naturally more emotional
yeah than men right due to
how the body is want to go through all
of that stuff
nature
knowing that though as a man
does that not so many people
we go to we go
to there we work we don't hit our boss
why are you hitting your man that's true
she said something you got to remember
you should try nobody
let me respond to that by the same that
you can't that's not a good example
because you're not in a relationship
with your boss
or maybe some people are but anyways
well the point i made
but your boss if your boss sleeps with
another woman
that has nothing you're not emotionally
upset about that yeah compared to
your boyfriend or your fiance cheating
on you someone that you've actually got
like an emotional attachment to an
intimate attachment to
cheating on you you're like you're a
grown-ass adult learn how to control
your emotions
you just build differently
yeah
and categorize women they're also men
that
are very emotional
[Laughter]
but women are chemically different every
single day yeah so that's a huge that's
the point i'm making women are like
every day we're chemically different
like that's why you're like i mean [ __ ]
why are you crazy today honestly
all right that's what i'm saying which
is fine but like you still as a girl
should be able to control your emotions
to the point you're not gonna hit a dude
like i just think there's no like
no excuse but just imagine if you are so
black
don't tell me i'm to stay my point my
thing is like you know like how women
you guys love to build this future like
you've seen this is it i see this guy
i'm 100 years old we're there
you know like you know what i mean i'm
dead
all of a sudden right let me let me make
one key point it's over what's going on
one key point over
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it doesn't have to be over if you don't
want it to be by the way like because a
guy can cheat on you and still love you
like i don't know very much